ant-man and the wasp rings Paul Rudd and
Evangeline Lilly back into the title
roles as a size changing superhero duo
along for the rider or their pals
families a collection of new villains
and more tiny buildings and gigantic Pez
dispensers and you can even try to count
all the action-packed movie occurs in
the space between Civil War and infinity
war Scott Lang's house arrest means that
he keeps a very separate life from his
one-off adventure with the Avengers so
it's not easy to find a whole lot of
Easter eggs in this film but there are a
good deal of references that dive deep
into Marvel lore and at least one
extremely meta cameo let's check out the
secrets of ant-man and the wasp however
small they may be stand the man let's
get the most obvious impossible to miss
cameo out of the way first you'll find
Stan Lee the co-creator of ant-man and
the man credited as one of the main
architects of the Marvel Comics universe
attempting to get into his car during
the second half of the film during the
car chase scene through the streets of
San Francisco in April 2018 it was
reported that Lee had filmed multiple
cameos at the same time not because of
fading health but because he simply
isn't into flying around to different
movie sets the same report confirmed
that he's already filmed his cameo in
Avengers 4 he is hoping we get to see
him for another 10 years of Marvel
movies Young Avengers even if you're
unfamiliar with Scott Lang in the comics
you can probably guess that is badass
daughter will one day become a superhero
herself it's clear that she desperately
wants to help out her dad
a brilliant kid in the comics she ends
up spending time at the Four Freedoms
Plaza with the Fantastic Four we're
surrounded by superheroes herself she
develops a taste for adventure and
eventually joins a Young Avengers for
now her conversations about being a
dad's partner in heroism are a
predictive but distant dream they'll
fight side by side someday and if
casting rumors are to be believed for
Avengers four she'll be back much sooner
than expected as a 16 year old kid
probably ready for a fight egghead and
Jimmy Jimmy Woo's appearance and ant-man
and the wasp isn't so much an easter egg
at a trip deep into Marvel's past
originally appearing in the comics in
1956 where is a government agent much
like years on the big screen
he's drifted in and out of secret
organizations for decades but his most
notable just for being a pretty good
agents as well as a very positive
deviation from the negative stereotypes
Asians face in the comics during the 50s
and 60s burrowed a little deeper is a
lie a star on the big screen he's a
father of ghosts but the comics tell a
very different story star first appeared
in 1962 s tales to astonish issue 38 as
the villainous egghead his first arch
nemesis was of course ant-man and his
grand plot was to simply turn all of ant
man's ants against him true love
prevails however and ant-man is not
betrayed by his ants despite eggheads
super science as far as the comics are
concerned it's star who helped Darren
cross develop his Yellow Jacket armor
the MCU star might not be such a good
guy after all either co-host with the
most perhaps the most meta reference and
the MCU was the appearance of comedian
and professional weirdo Tim Heidecker as
well both Captain Daniel Gubler spelled
with three o's hydaker is the co-host of
the satirical on cinema at the cinema
video series alongside Greg Turk in turn
were the two hosts battle for movie
superiority and to get the best movie
cameos your remember Turkey internists a
baskin-robbins manager and the original
ant-man a cameo which enraged him to the
point where he allegedly paid $15,000
for his brief cameo in Fox's Fantastic
Four reboot as Reed Richards useless
father Tim returns now of the best cameo
yet hosting San Francisco whale boat
tours what does it all mean
only that Paul Rudd hangs out with some
pretty funny people I'm gonna give it
five bags of popcorn
along with maybe ant-man DVD that I
would collect some residuals on mass
media obviously ant-man isn't the first
movie to play with the idea of objects
and creatures of unusual sizes 1954 then
was all about massive irradiated ant
invaders ant-man and the wasp references
this in two ways it's a feature that
Scott's hope and cassia watching at the
end of the film after Scott finally
allows his daughter to have a real
adventure as a super tiny person
additionally when Bill Foster is
cornered by PIMs giant ants and his labs
theaters it's them but if you know your
1970s movies you'll also recognize
Animal House playing on TV in an early
scene specifically we get a scene in
which a very drug induced conversation
centers around the idea of an entire
universe being contained in an atom in a
fingernail my fingernail could be one
tiny universe that's basically the
definition of the quantum realm thanks
to the Enlightenment stoner comedy
single frames many viewers left the
original ant-man with the distinct
impression that that seemed Janet Van
Dyne trapped in the quantum realm even
for a split second of course it couldn't
really be proven until home viewers
could pause frame selectively at home
but we knew she was there this time
around Marvel's Kevin Feige has
definitely confirmed that we'll have to
wait for a home release to see the
single frames of MCU hints at director
Peyton Reed has slipped into the movie's
various realms we already know that dr.
strange got a quick view of the quantum
realm as he zipped through the
multiverses and that the trip has made
perilous by time vortices and we also
know that Avengers 4 seems to be playing
fast and loose with time-travel and the
possibility of multiverses with so many
ways to traverse time and space anything
is possible and anything can be in there
we just won't know what's up until we
hit the pause button one thing is for
certain it's not really the Marvel
Universe until we see MODOK I am MODOK
I am the ultimate in human machine
interface I am designed only for con
class make it happen Marvel thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your left a
[Music]